we have a pretty epic Water Crisis in
Mexico City and so we figured let's
start harvesting rain water in these
neighborhoods where people need it is an
organization that designs and installs
rainwater harvesting systems we've
installed something like 24
000 or 25 000 rainwater harvesting
systems just using Revenue
[Music]
foreign
the rainwater harvesting systems that we
install are pretty simple it teaches
people how to harvest filter and
potabilize water at home the whole thing
starts with the roof of the house which
is the catchment surface so we work with
the family so that they have a very
clear understanding of keeping the roof
as clean as possible the water that
falls off of that roof we Channel
Through gutters and pipes we chlorinate
that water we do simple sedimentation
process that allows fine particles of
sediments to settle in the tank and then
after that we pass it through a pretty
simple filtration system that then feeds
water to the rest of the house and we
can get water of whatever quality we
need from kind of generally use domestic
water we can get purified water that you
could bottle yeah
[Music]
[Music]
harvesting rainwater it's an ancient
practice that people have done forever
and like just kind of largely abandoned
as we kind of adopted other ideas of how
we should get water and what modern
water access should look like but in
that Pursuit there's all of these
millions of people that just kind of
fell through the cracks and were left in
these continuously precarious situations
living with often very very small
amounts of water often with water very
poor quality often paying an enormous
amount of personal to their income
getting water
foreign
[Music]
Mexico City is one of the top 10 cities
rated most likely to run out of water in
the world by The Nature Conservancy
we've done a lot of work getting policy
past Mexico now has requirements for
rainwater harvesting systems to be
integrated into new construction very
fundamentally we need to start being
able to use the water that we have and
reduce the amount of water that we need
to pull out of the ground and the most
direct and simplest way to do that is to
start actually using the rain water that
falls on us
foreign
I would trace the story of Mexico City's
Water Crisis to an event that happened
in 1607 when the Viceroy of New Spain
based out of Mexico City decided that
Mexico City was going to be a dry land
City like Madrid and made the decision
to drain the lake of this cocoa as the
city was built on this old lake bed the
soft ground underneath would sink and
the result of channeling all of the rain
out of the city as quickly as possible
to avoid flooding has also stopped the
process of recharging the groundwater
and that's kind of a core of the Water
Crisis in Mexico City
Generations
[Music]
[Music]
we've gotten this deeply intimate Vision
into how people are experiencing the
Water Crisis and I think it's something
that will end up being relevant to many
many cities throughout the world what's
being developed here in Mexico City